hey Lee how are you it's so good to see
you it's so good to see you
what are you wearing is that like a
peasant blouse what is that oh yes a
traditional 1800s nightgown that I have
been living in since quarantine oh you
look like one of the little women
someone appreciates that oh I appreciate
it yeah it's so funny I was downstairs
and I said I have to go upstairs and my
wife said why and I said I've got to go
talk to Kaley Cuoco and her nightgown
that's not that did not go over well
well once you see the nightgown you know
it's not exactly a turn-on of a
nightgown it's more of a repellent you
know the thing about that is it's not
like a nightie that is a real Jew like
Charles Dickens nightgown you know
that's what Scrooge wore when he went to
bed and got visited by the ghosts with a
little fire lamp at night when I and I
hold this and I have a hat I just really
get into the character of that so yeah
you nailed it on the head
thank you do you know that also I would
say the plus of that kind of night
whereas you can wear that out right oh
yes yes the only place I've worn it
because I feel like I can get away with
it is this grocery store called air one
okay so you know you can wear anything
at air one and you're automatically cool
there are hipsters at airline so you can
walk in in that and there doesn't even
have to be a pandemic you can tell them
you quote oh I wasn't talking about I've
been wearing this for years in the air
one yeah
sales of alcohol are through the roof
people are drinking more yeah what about
you
are you drinking more I feel like all
I've done for the past six weeks is eat
drink and pick up [ __ ]
it's all I've done I hope you have dogs
or else you're just doing it as a hobby
didn't help everybody out I have nothing
else to do
yeah yeah hey dude what why is kaley
cuoco picking up with the dog [ __ ] what
are you doing playing fire yeah yeah
we've been drinking an excessive amount
I really have to tell you my husband is
like a really great book he's not a
bartender but he makes up all these
drinks for me and he we have a full bar
and it's it's been um we've we've formed
problems at this way
well first question what are you
drinking okay so my favorite drink is an
old fashioned but Carl my husband's name
is Carl he has created the Carl
fashioned which involves scotch get into
my belly a scotch and it is so
delightful fresh orange but it's really
important to get the right glass and the
right measurements so it's perfect if
we've had a lot of those ok what time of
day do you start that's my second
question and this is important well you
know I don't want to be tacky I'll start
the minute we hang up this interview
okay well people think this is happening
at 11 o'clock at night I'm gonna tell
them now it is right now because we're
pre taping this it is 11:30 8:00 in the
morning I don't start before noon that's
just ridiculous right start at noon
you'll start okay good and how many of
these would you have I'm not sure they
go down really really really easily and
then all of a sudden I'm asleep and I
wake up and we do it all over again hey
and you're already dressed for bed so
you're all set you know Conan I've been
living as if no one will ever see me
again
really yes just the end of the food and
that hanging out it's like not really
doing in my hair makeup like I'm just
kind of I'm just kind of living like I
feel like I'm never going back to work
again it's very straight even doing this
with you I feel like you're the only one
that seen me which is not gonna be face
you should just keep me on in the corner
okay put me in the corner and you and
your husband can pass me and I'll be
like yeah it's really creepy it's one of
the creepier things I've suggested hey
kar yeah how you doing yeah yeah
well okay I have to admit I'm doing that
a little bit too I'll eat things now
that I would never eat normally and I
have this feeling like it doesn't matter
what happens to me now it's weird it's
almost like like okay you can understand
this I'm eating as if I'm at craft
service so anyone that's you know craft
service obviously people know when
you're shooting the people that take
care of you and feed you but it's food
you would never have in your house right
anytime you're doing anything in show
business there's a table and it's filled
with all the stuff that no health
conscious person there's always like a
nod to others a little bowl of
vegetables yeah but then there's
goldfish crackers pound cake Nutter
butters
he's Nutter Butter in everything it's
it's ridiculous and when this all
started we all went crazy right we were
taking everything off the shelves
freaking out I mean I have so many years
it's like as if I had kids the stuff
that would go in their lunchbox we
didn't even have kids yeah weird fruit
roll-ups who does that
yeah those are good though those can
also be used as crude tools you know I
mean you can find things with meth